Robert going back to was at 2005 so when
you made sex and sushi you also acted
right you were one of the main
characters yeah okay how was that for
you as a non-actor or maybe you had some
prior experience I didn't have any
experience but again we were making a
sort of a light comedy so it wasn't like
a heavy drama kind of thing and I knew
would be improvised so to me it wasn't a
big deal i don't think acting is such a
big deal necessarily i just think it's
sort of the same kind of philosophy like
don't take it all so seriously my
girlfriend at the time I gave her a
two-minute acting lesson it was um don't
be afraid don't be scared if somebody's
nervous it conveys its so either wooden
and stiff and that's such a turn off to
be yourself just be yourself I know
you're playing a character but just
whatever you're inhabiting that
character so just be yourself and three
listen just listen and it's you know
it's um it's not this it's you know it's
not a big deal acting to me and it's
particularly something like that I don't
see the point of taking it too seriously
what do you think about showing actors
the dailies or just just a couple
screenshots oh yeah as I just said it's
you know it's a mistake I mean I had an
actress who I showed regrettably i
showed the dailies to and i was told
never show the leads dailies I don't
know that's a common thing but as after
i did so she was so conscious of how she
looked indicator it became you know it
was a big mistake so i don't recommend
it yeah I don't know everybody's
different though I mean like for me
again it's not such a big deal and sort
of the yeah it's like it can be loose
and that kind of stuff and some actors
are just you know I think that goes back
to the casting if you're I didn't know
any better but and I by the way she's
not in the finished film so I'm not
throwing anybody under the bus was in
the movie but yeah I mean yeah period
did you watch yourself because you
became then became the DP how was that
for you did you start feeling
self-conscious or did it actually
for you up it totally freed me up it was
just like yeah it's because you can tell
when someone's up uncomfortable it's so
clear so you know it's how did it for
you up why just because it was like I
could see when I was uncomfortable and I
could see when I wasn't when I was
comfortable and you know it's it's it's
it's pretty conspicuous when you're
looking at it so going back with with
some other if you become a director
again on another project right you will
never I think it goes back into the
casting you mean that in terms of
directing actors or just showing an
actor what they look like on screen
before the film is finished I'm not
gonna be I I don't think I'm gonna be
casting any anyone who's never acted
before so you know presumably they will
have done some acting so yeah it's all
goes down to the casting you know you
those are the decisions you make before
you pick the actor is this person
natural is a person uptight is this
person really you know self-conscious
that kind of stuff yeah it's in the
casting
you